my journey to the Hellfire was detail
out of hundreds of Muslims who attack me
now get this only one took his time to
talk and explain things to me and even
apologize on behalf of the other Muslims
and for that I'm eternally grateful
[Music]
Smith hundred allah assalamu alaikum
greetings of peace welcome to the Deen
show I got our guests flying all the way
from Dallas shaykh abdullah how are you
sheikh hi Mila I'm good how you doing
how you been bless them we met how long
several years back yeah that was
probably like in 2010 probably yeah
Houston you keeping up keeping up don't
try madam I shot a lot I'll be like
Eddie good luck tell me so now you
accepted Islam 20 years ago correct
roughly yeah like 1997 nice let's start
with that why'd you accept Islam I mean
you know primarily I mean as many of us
have we've had a past in that past you
don't you know it's been a trial and
it's been a means for us to think about
life and you know I used to be heavily
into hip-hop heavily into it and there
were some people we used to battle back
in the days and you know battle is
basically we'd say poetry about one
another and speak about one another and
sometimes it could get kind of sometimes
depending to get kind of violent as me
the youth know nowadays battling is kind
of coming back in the picture no one's
back oh yes definitely no there's no
music but they're going at each other
but it's violent talking it's a lot of
you know it's a lot of bragging and
talking about what they'll do to each
other and what they've done etc kind of
similar to the Jackie Leo of Islam you
know yeah we used to do that you used to
battle back and forth yeah I used to do
that that's kind of like I want got M&M
big right definitely like I'm eight mile
and stuff like that mmm and a lot of
these would you call emcees you know
masters of ceremony that was that that
was a trait you have to be able to
control it hold your own you were really
good out there I'm Neela you know I kind
of held my own I could say that you know
but that's kind of what I used to do and
the ones that I used to battle were
Muslim but when I knew Islam all I knew
was the Nation of Islam right so when I
would talk to them it was based on that
premise being that okay so so y'all
worship y'all say that there's a God you
know when his name is so-and-so
you're like no no no that's not the
Aslam we represent we represent Sunni
Islam so I let on to more human
munication even though they were kind of
somewhat my enemies especially when it
came to the microphone but other than
that who are your enemies then once I
call me to Islam uh-huh because when it
when we go to the club or when we you
know being that that that element it was
like okay we're gonna battle each other
so one time we were in a gathering and
it was kind of a gathering that you know
the law you know preserve us and forgive
us but they started talking about Islam
again and we were really into martial
law new world order Illuminati you know
the year 2000 etc so I asked over okay
so what are you gonna do when the Big
Brother plan you know the Big Brother
claims like the microchip is gonna be
injected the people and so they said
it's all in the hands of Allah and
that's what sparked it man that's what
really just said okay Allah and that's I
started asking a lot of questions and
what attracted me Eddie really was told
he'd you know the oneness of God you
know the oneness of God and exemplifying
that and showing that in your life and
everything that you do from saying
inshallah to praying five times a day to
not drinking to being nice to your
mother that's you know may be very
envious towards you and not nice toward
you because you're trying to you know
come into being faithful to other than
their religion so that was very
intriguing to me man and you know the
more they talked about it I remember
they kept saying in châlons Charlie
miles like Westchester stuff mention
today is that now that's inshallah and
just from them explaining inshallah I
was like okay this is something that's
real I mean it's not superficial it's
something that's real and I'm really
feeling it but as they were explaining
it to me I was showing that it was okay
for my like a you know like what we call
a cypher just vibing with one another
you know just talking and kind of going
in the metaphysical but I wasn't showing
that I was really you know this was
really piercing my heart and it was
being it was a it was a problem for me
because that would mean I'd have to
accept what they're on and we used to
battle each other so I was like yeah you
following them now so I had one question
I remember that question was okay and I
thought this question was just gonna end
it was gonna dead it and it was okay
what do y'all think about Jesus because
mine yah was a Christian and they said
no you can't be a Muslim unless you
believe in Jesus and that cause that
caused a problem for me
because I said okay this may be
something that is true but I said how
come I didn't know about this before how
come you know I've known them for a
while I never knew about this Islam
thing all I knew was you know Malcolm X
that's all I knew and it was primarily
focused towards the african-american
demographic and I said no it's for
everyone we're certainly Muslims and
Sunda means following Muhammad so I'm
like okay saad mohammed like none of
mohammed peace must be upon him was a
prophet comes a chronological order in
conclusion it was the tow he'd it was
the oneness of God and showing gratitude
in every aspect of your life to the best
of your ability is what attracted me
that's really retracted were you a
practicing Christian Christian or just
because you you were just like you know
your parents are Christian and you just
kind of like one church on Sundays or
you weren't connected much at all to the
Bible or church or what was your status
as far as where would you rate yourself
as a Christian man I probably about of
four or five you know I was I wasn't a
practicing Christian I didn't have
dreams and aspirations of becoming a
deacon or anything like that it was more
of just I was a mainstream I said I was
Christian I go to the church every now
and then if I felt bad on Saturday night
and go Sunday morning if my mom really
wanted me to go you know I would go but
I wasn't someone that would read the
Bible voluntarily on a weekly basis did
you know the Creed very well yes I knew
mainstream The Creeper no I won't say
very very well but I understood the
basics of it being that there was a
Trinity and you know that there may be
different sects of it that there's some
considered Jesus as God and some can
don't consider him as you know as God he
may be the son of God you know I was
well familiar with that mm-hmm yes so
you said that now what really caught
your attention what really had you
moving towards Islam was a toe heat
that's translated we could translate it
as pure monotheism how would you how
would you translate that pure monotheism
if I said yeah pure monotheism Innis
it's good that you mentioned pure
monotheism because what we may consider
in other phases is monotheism but in
actuality it's directing all forms of
worship even when it comes to
intercession which is I think the
demarcating factor you know between
Islam and everything else is that you
know it goes directly to God to the
creator of the heavens of the earth
whatever some of our Christian Brothers
just as humanity they say okay no no we
believe in one got two we just pray
because you know the Bible tells us that
no one comes to the Father except
through me meaning Jesus so we just say
in Jesus name right but we still believe
in one God that's a great question
yeah the thing is no one comes to the
Father except through me but how is that
manifested through me right we say the
same thing no one goes to Allah except
through the sunnah of the prophet
sallallaahu honey listen limp peace and
blessings be upon him so in the meaning
way his approvals and things that he did
whether it's obligatory or even
recommended but that is what we believe
is the means to obtaining God's love and
forgiveness there's a lot of Mitch's in
the Quran you know so we say yes to that
but how that's manifested and how that's
acted out is definitely true and that's
where the problem or the difference may
lie so we believe in Jesus and no one
got to a lot except through Jesus at
that time but it wasn't through
worshiping him and when we say do
anything in things in Jesus's name we
have to be fair you know when we speak
to a Christian we have to be fair on how
we question them or how we have our
dialogue with them so when we say okay
and Jesus just say what do you mean by
in Jesus's name some of them may not
even be able to articulate that and to
be fair Muslims may not be able to
articulate bismillah in the name of
Allah and how that goes back to our
Creed and how it's a statement of our
Creed and how that statement end of
itself is totally different than any
other cream so when Jesus's name does it
mean that in the name of Jesus you are
indirectly interceding with his name and
with what he's done and quote-unquote
believing that he sacrificed himself in
the blood of Jesus that's where it could
be different for the Muslims and we say
Muslims no we don't believe that but we
say in that Jesus being that he's a
prophet in and of himself we believe
that but in the name of something is
seeking blessings and and and actions of
who you are saying in the name of so
that's why we say in the name of Allah
so you're having these hip-hop battles
Islam is coming up yeah and now you like
the you know the teachings of Islam that
just submit your will only to God pure
monotheism what happens next
yeah man I you know the first time that
they met with me I was like mom not
gonna you know because one of them asked
me okay what do you think about I was
like that's cool you know it's alright
you know because I was there for another
purpose but I said it's alright you know
you're there to win a battle
well that it wasn't a battle it was
something else it was it was a meeting
yeah so was there any prize money for
these battles were people getting paid
oh yeah there's the status that you'd
like grow up in ranks it was primarily
the status it was primarily the status
it was right next to a club so when
people be lineup for the club they would
see that there is the latest you know
music coming out the latest
instrumentals and you know we were it
was just a different vibe because a lot
of it from the east coast yes okay so
now you're there and you're there for
whatever reason what happens next yeah
so I mean you know III
you know I went home I started asking
questions started asking my mom
questions my god I never forget when I
asked her about God you know she got so
happy she called her friends over to the
house and I didn't know what was going
on and he I had no idea so next thing he
knows about four or five friends coming
over she called me the living room she
says okay gather hands we gathered our
hands together and then they started
praying and I'm just like I'm just a
band my mom I'm trying to do the best
that I can
right and you know some of them started
jumping and don't be jumping
yeah like jumping jacks kind of like
jumping jacks but without the swing
because they hold their hands you know
then so it started speaking in language
it's like you know the language is they
call tongues oh yeah I've heard that
yeah so tongues is basically like the
spirit quote-unquote comes into you the
roar right comes into you and you say a
language that's not understood so that's
what started happening and I'm used to
that because I see my mom do it you know
every she's waking up and doing her 200
version I mean until this day you know
it's like 3:00 in the morning she's on
the edge of the bed hands clasped
together and she's doing the tongues she
started off the English but when you get
into it it's like euphoric right you're
doing the tongue so they were doing that
some of them fell down you know they're
sweating and things of that nature and
then after that they all hugged me and
said congratulations you are born again
so I knew were born again was but to be
fair I didn't really I didn't know if I
was supposed to feel it right then if I
had to wait to go and get back I didn't
know what it was so I just didn't fit
and I was searching for that feeling you
know I'm praying to God if this is the
right way but I just couldn't feel it so
I kept asking my mom questions and what
I did is I also went around to different
mosques and this was a test for me I go
around different mosque and all I asked
about was decreed because what
that I'm thankful to Allah for you know
is that I understood that religion was
based on its Creed not the actions of
men mm-hmm that's one thing I understood
is a non-muslim and I go I run around
the mosque and the thing that really
intrigued me was that all of them said
the same thing when it came to the creek
they all said look we worship Allah and
no one else we worship Him by himself
there's everything I started mentioning
different aspects of worship which I
didn't even think was an aspect of
worship but it was a manifestation of
worship in Islam and that was D to me
also because it showed more greatness to
God right so with that I just said you
know what this may be something that is
true and I remember wanting them from
Libya me a lot apparently Allah preserve
him in my châlons you know when I went
to ask about Islam I had a just looking
like I was you know in their life or
whatever and um he uh he said he got
remember he said uh brother you can be
better than me it doesn't matter black
white yellow green it doesn't matter
it's all about your fear of Allah and he
pointed to his heart and then he showed
me how to make wudu min he went in the
back and he showed me how to make and
you know mind you the imam of the masjid
is white though born looked fairly
elderly i'm coming you know i had gold
teeth in my mouth and I'm you know I'm
over there and he shows me how to make
will do you're not Muslim I'm not Muslim
yeah and this is right around the area
where we used to hang her out hangout or
whatever so you know he goes in I'm
thinking that this is the priest he's
the leader yeah and he's showing me how
to make will do it he makes will do and
he you know he's partially bald and so
his hair was all over the place after he
was done make it will do and I'm like
man he took the time off to come and
show me this act you know washing his
feet and what minutes I said I mean
that's that's humble and I really humble
meaning and I said man that's really it
made me feel that Islam is a real
universal religion and there's no
hierarchy except with knowledge and fear
of Allah and that's what he said we said
you could be better than in front of his
congregation is that you could be better
than me it doesn't matter
that's what really intrigued me and then
from then I went to the mosque on my
house and then I embraced Islam knows ma
sha was amongst a whole bunch of Jamaat
that I believe brothers or brothers that
you know a call how long after this will
do incident man this was about a week a
week because within that week this is
like a giving you snapshots man and then
that week I went to what was called a
Kappa beach party yeah
and that was are you saying out with
some guys you know every now and then
and um the cabo beach party is kind of
like it's something that happens in
atlanta wednesday the name of it but
it's kind of different fraternity I
can't meet what is it yeah I think it is
yeah yeah but it's where you go to the
beach and you stay there night at the
beach for maybe one or two nights yeah
and you just it's it's kind of like obey
your thirst you know I mean so obey your
thirst free clothes I'll be your design
obey your desires exactly exactly
exactly so you know when I went there I
was I said you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna just look and how people are
acting mm-hmm and look and see is it's
just like is this what life is really
about like after this then what so when
I went there you know the friends with
like a man we're about to go here about
to go ahead
I saw nah man I just want to walk on the
sea wall the sea walls in Galveston
where like borders the the sea so I just
walk and I just started thinking and
then I looked around I saw people half
dressed
I saw people trying to get their Mack on
you know guys trying to talk to girls
and you know say come on up with us and
people playing music and acting crazy
like is this really what life is about
is this really what matters would this
be beneficial for me and then from there
I said man I got to make a choice I
really got to make a choice in them
because life is gonna end
how old were you at that time man I was
twenty-two very almost twenty years old
yeah I was 20 and then from there I said
man I gotta make I have to do something
about this this knowledge that I have it
was a tightness in my chest man so
finally just how Allah wishes in the
Quran it was a tight feeling that I had
in my chest I said I said I'm just gonna
go and do it so I went to the mosque in
my house and you had enough now you knew
and you knew what you needed to know I
knew what I knew yes yes because the the
the the oneness of God was firm I
already had that I think the fifth row
was mashallah
it wasn't tampered that much and Allah
knows best you know but I said no I
believe in a creator no one can judge me
and he's the only one that I go to
that's what I've always felt you know
but he didn't feel that with with what
you had at home I didn't feel that yeah
yeah I didn't feel that with your mom
and Christianity right I didn't feel
that because I had a problem with going
to someone that they believed died to
ask him for God like characteristics
that was a problem for me you know it
was it was just difficult for me to
grasp and understand so when I you know
left that cabo beach party about a week
you know might do this man I went to the
maasen in my house and then I wondered I
went to embrace Islam and you know by
the permission of Allah I was a lot of
brothers there and they embraced me in
that kind of healthy situation also and
from there that was it it was just my
goal my goal primarily for me you know a
lot of Congress it may be social or
educational but me was primarily
educational now that I understood that
this was true and I firmly believed it I
was like man I want to learn I want to
learn more about it now you know it's
interesting that it's just the Creed
it's decreed that now you're not
attacking Christianity or Christians or
usually you'll see when people they go
towards you know another way of life
they choose and me it's a free country
free choice it's on them you know God
will judge them at the end in the next
life but you see them coming hard
you know attacking you know being really
belligerent and going out of their way
you know to attack Islam but you don't
see them attack the creed we're talking
about the Creed adjusted for us you know
we don't want to worship Jesus we want
to worship who Jesus worship fair right
leave it at that
and that's what you wanted to do we're
over here attacking Christianity and you
know or Christians but we're just saying
just pure monotheism right and that's
that man that's such a good point you
mentioned because you know separating
the axe from the from the person that
does the act is very important and it's
an Islamic principle you know what I
mean I mean you know you know a lost my
dolly meshes in the Quran well that's a
simple Adina get the urn him and do any
life here so below hard won't be later
he says and do not curse the people that
call to other than Allah for they will
they will speak against Allah or curse
Allah without knowledge mhm and that's a
great principle that we learned you know
subhanAllah being that it's called
closing the doors to the pathways sudde
that are you're closing the doors to
pathways that can lead to something
that's not beneficial to them or even
some Muslims so when you curse that
person because they're Christian or you
say that they're animals you say they're
kinsey or pigs or things of that nature
what benefit is it going to bring and I
think that's what this verse and many
other verses especially in the Seattle
you know life of the process along it
brings forth that light you know sheds
light on that that you have to be wise
and understanding weak the acting it of
itself from an Islamic principle is
something that's not praised but we
don't curse people and speak down upon
them and belittling well that is
a really important point and we let's
touch upon that we'll get back to your
story because recently we got a an email
from someone who was reaching out and he
had made a comment on one of the videos
that we had posted about a Russian
Jewish lady who ended up accepting Islam
and he had said something about I'm
happy for her as I am for the thousands
of millions of others finding solace in
Islam however when I commented on the
video he's saying and to be honest my
comment was he sees omitting it was some
somewhat provoking but he says that he
does that with all religions he said I
said that out of nearly 3000 gods out
there being worshipped by today's world
population I hope that this one in
particular is right for you and then he
says that's all now what followed my
comment was a Murad of negativity that's
the only way I can explain it I was
called all sorts of names including
animal there were verses quoted at me my
journey to the hell for iowa's detail
out of hundreds of Muslims who attacked
me now get this only one took his time
to talk and explain things to me and
even apologize on behalf of the other
Muslims and for that I'm eternally
grateful he just touched his heart and I
will never forget the guy now I've been
following you for so this is someone
who's coming obviously for some reason
he's been guided here right he's in our
watching observing so he's talking about
because of this he unfollowed us on
Facebook and it just basically it's a
long email to summarize in short he was
attacked he was insulted someone stepped
up so out of like ten people who
insulted him there was more but out of
ten one came forward and you know and
did it the right way and explain things
to him and try to reason would try to
give him you know you know the the real
essence of Islam etc etc but then he was
very disheartened and how he was named
called and ridiculed and whatnot this is
not the way Muslims should be acting a
lot of times I even I want to give the
benefit at all because I know there's a
lot of trolls out there I know there's
people out there paid you know to attack
and you know behind keyboards because
true practicing Muslim doesn't use foul
language like that at anybody doesn't do
opposite to what the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him you know our example
and and and things that are displeasing
to the Almighty to the Creator this is
not the way if you're trying to
exemplify the best of manners and
character you're actually earning you
know the the anger of a law you're doing
the opposite of that that's not what you
should be and your your hindering you
know the Dawa right you're pushing
people away just like in this case what
are your thoughts on that oh man
that's a lot and there's a lot there I
mean firstly when I when I see when I
hear that or see that you know
subhanAllah it's about you know on for
you know firstly advice to the Muslims
we have to be aware and cognizant of the
fact of when we do that if we do that if
we feel that you know sometimes we have
to ask ourselves do we do that for self
gratification like to feel good about
our Deen because when we think of the
word is and might and the Dean of might
being mighty in your religion doesn't
necessitate belittling other religions
or let's say belittling other
practitioners of those religions it
doesn't necessitate that it's for you to
have integrity of who you are and pride
of who you are but not in the same token
it doesn't mean that you have to
belittle others you have proud of who
you are you're you're you okay with
being in your own skin that I'm a Muslim
I pray five times a day I'm a Muslim
that I wear hijab I wait to get married
I don't do these things and I understand
the reasoning behind that when one
understands why they do what they do and
how that reason of why they do what they
do is a manifestation of worship the
more that they learn and this is a key
word the more that they learn about who
their Lord is this is what brings the
Salaam the Sakina the will call the
peace the tranquility and the nonchalant
is if you are being nonchalant and I'm a
Muslim and I'm totally okay with that so
when someone insulted my religion
it's definitely built primarily off of
ignorance
you know we have to understand that
people are still entering a religion and
the word ignorant is not a word that is
I'm using to belittle people just you
just don't know ignorant you just don't
know and it's okay not how many Muslims
don't know a lot about their religion
yeah
I mean starting with myself there's
still some always gonna be a learner you
know that's not that that's the key
rooted the problem is that people many
Muslims are ignorant about their Deen
and they react emotionally exactly would
you say exactly
yeah they react emotion you finance a
pond along with a lot of the youth yeah
I'm saying a lot of the youth they have
that zeal of being a Muslim but do they
understand what it means primarily from
who a lot is and who he is not and how
that manifests in your life and the best
way to see the manifestation of that the
best way to see how that's acted out is
in the life of the Prophet Muhammad's
Ilana was on them the way he acted with
Muslims where he acted with non-muslims
you know some of the reasons for these
chapters being revealed you know so when
learning about that and then asking a
lot to make us firm in their religion we
don't just go off half Hazzard Lee and
speak badly to that person that's the
first thing looking at self
gratification and looking at okay are we
supposed to tell people about this way
of life if we all agree that we are
supposed to do that how is it beneficial
by speaking badly to that person and
talking at that person how are they
going to come to the religion how many
times and you Eddie you've probably seen
it yourself I know I've seen in myself
when it's like you have a person that's
speaking badly to you or even let's not
even say in religion just a family
member or something and you remember
that day that they were patient we they
could have went off on you they could
have done some and they had the right to
let's just say but they didn't you
remember years later man that person
could have been like this I mean that
person could have been like that to me
but there was a reason why they weren't
so in this case Muslims don't have that
right to go off on that person or to
speak badly to the person to call them
names right but what is the benefit if
you were to be patient with them and
just say look they're probably saying
that because they're probably going
through their phases and they're
probably searching and this is the way
that they are showing that they are
searching yeah you know what we usually
recommend I mean there's an ayat that
actually discusses this where I lost
talking about repelling evil with what
is better right so what we usually tell
people is you know especially now when
people are commenting on these on these
videos let's say there's a harsh comment
and then you can tell us what you
suggest we thank people first and
foremost exactly we think
for coming to visit our channel we thank
them for being inquisitive and then we
say unfortunately you've been
misinformed about some things but we're
here to help
exert here to help call us let's talk
that's excellent man that's excellent no
I mean again you know one thing I tell a
lot of people nowadays like when she
mentioned number one time we had an
outreach program at this Masjid and you
know we were leading it in subhanAllah
you saw this girl walk in she opened the
door just enough to fit in the door and
close the door and stood there you could
tell this is her first time in a monster
you know very out of place you know and
I knew this mastered the brothers you
know it was something very not knows it
wasn't normal for them but there was one
brother we did we called me enforcer he
was a brother that security kids all
know him mess with them you know so he
was a standard look I spoke to her and I
said go talk to her you know this is why
we're here it's open house this is for
them you know so he went over then he
started talking it was very it was very
awkward for them but this is very
important for us as Muslims when talking
about outreach we know that Dow is
obligatory upon us we know that
implementing Islam to our actors is
obligatory upon us there will be those
awkward situations you have to just
surpass that so when I spoke to her
window speak at trial you know the first
thing I tell a lot of them is you know I
want to thank you just like you
mentioned for having enough courage to
come to a mosque post 9/11 and ask about
Islam amongst Muslims on our on our
grounds right that takes a lot of
courage especially for women
especially for women so you have to you
have to like you said to make them feel
comfortable and thank them for that
because I know as Muslims that's going
to a church firstly we would have issues
with that as always if we didn't have
issues with that it would be maybe a
cultural relevance issue to really just
say no I don't want to go to that
struggle yeah so we just stay back in
our bubble tell us you have actually you
specialize in helping not only your
graduate from Medina University you've
been really involved in the Dawa
educating people you have a website now
yes you it's particular Mullens
tell us about this work and how people
can go ahead and find more about it no
how many like 2010 and I started an
organization cuz every summer I would
call back come back from Medina Medina I
would see people coming to Islam next
time you see where he's at where she at
you don't know where they're at so I
said there has to be something
organize and particularly from converts
for converts right or we say reverts
would have you that's that it focuses on
their social and educational spiritual
development so that's called new you KN
e W letter U and new U is spoken like a
website esta website new york right w KN
e w u org and it concentrates on
knowledge of creator knowledge of self
and knowledge of purpose and this is
what we call the process of progression
unlike the knowledge of creator not just
self and knowledge of purpose having
knowledge of these three things and
being gradual with that and trying to
the best of your ability is what will
take you out of the realm of being a new
Muslim or convert to a just a Muslim
that's what we all just aspire to to be
so that's really what the organization
concentrates on and that's the mission
is to serve as a resource for the social
educational and spiritual development of
new and renewed Muslims worldwide so we
say renewed is kind of like we say in
Christianity born again I mean you know
people that have they were born Muslim
but they never they weren't really
practicing Islam they were born they
never really started praying until it
was a lecture there was a friend let's
be honest there was a boyfriend or
girlfriend in college and that person
convert to Islam it was a catalyst for
them to come back to the Dean this is
the demographic that we really
concentrate on you know what I'm saying
and having events social and educational
events for them on a consistent basis
for them to gradually grow in their
religion as as a Muslim we could you say
as a good civilian as a as a upright
human being let's finish it off with you
finally accepting Islam that moment how
was it what happened
you came in leading up to the Shahada
and taking the shot oh man it was it was
really always topping when I came into
Islam it was like those two things the
weight of confusion was off of my
shoulders and the smoke was clear and
that's why I said knowledge of purpose
not just so for knowledge of creator
because knowledge is what will increase
you in your relationship to an
individual you know more about that
individual increase your relationship
with the love amor not like them so the
same case with enlighten methanol law is
much much higher than example when you
know more about a law it increases your
opportunity of getting closer to them
because you know more about
you know more about his greatness so
when I became Muslim it was really
around that I said man now I know who
I'm really worshipping and how to show
that from dealing with my mother dealing
with my neighbor dealing with a guy in
Walmart you know the convenience store
to dealing with my my Muslim brothers
you know that that may be racist or they
make you know not be racist yet cetera
so when I understood that everything
revolves around that I said really the
smoke is clear I know how to live my
life and that was knowledge of purpose
so just having that knowledge made it
very very very easy for me to had the
formula I live my life which is
worshiping Allah by himself and try my
level best and now you ended up checking
Shahada and here we are now yeah I mean
up take a shower I'm here with Eddie on
the Dean so well yeah so that's open now
for anybody watching if they're at that
you know crossroads they like the pure
monotheism they want to live purpose and
now they're tuning in what direction
would have ice do you give them right
there they've stayed up late they
watching us or there was you know they
got ahold of us and out there they're
there they're almost there
not definitely I mean subhanAllah is
telling other imran you know that's upon
allah you know we on the website you can
order a free package and we send it out
to you and it has some contents in there
and you know they leave their numbers so
not a not a day or week goes by i talked
to someone you think that everybody
would know about it right but you find
somebody in a city that you've never
heard of before you know there was a
sister she was a sophomore in high
school she embraced islam her and her
friend mash it is two hours away you
know and they're so thankful just to get
a call you know so those are the ones
that soupçon they really need help they
really need someone just to call them if
you are someone that is converted to
Islam and you know you may have that
friend firstly try to find someone that
can serve as a friend for you someone
that you can call and you can count on
to ask these questions and if not you
could contact us we'll do our best to
contact you and answer any questions
that you have and if you're someone
that's a renewed Muslim you know make
sure that you're around that environment
of people and a social and educational
development that can really help you and
assist you in growing and if you're
someone that's a seasoned quote/unquote
Muslim you know you're either have the
time the expertise or the sufficient
elements to help these organizations so
just take it upon yourself to be
and when we call we have summers called
convert coaches we educate those that
are seasoned Muslims that know these
elements of Islam to go out and serve as
a coach to these converts but just
really in the beginning stages for that
those embraced Islam stay strong keep in
contact with someone
preferably that's a Muslim that it has
education and keep it contact with them
and put your hands up - Allah is the
reason that you came into Islam was your
heart accepted something and that
feeling that you had try to get back to
that feeling and the way that you can
get back to that feeling primarily is
you know prostrating and putting the
answer to a lot to ask him because he's
the ultimate one that can guide I makes
you beautiful thank you so much I
pleasure talking with you and Charlotte
will have a back soon sometime is that
like a boy I was like looking may Allah
bless you I miss you too sometime makeup
salons here he gets